remember the custard toast trend of
2022. why'd we stop doing that so let's
bring it back but let's bag
[Music]
get your bagel and you get bagel bagel
bagel whatever you want
me now normally I would say that
hollowing out a bagel is offensive but
in this case you need to build a moat
step one complete next we make custard
one egg couple tablespoons of full fat
Greek yogurt we splash of maple even
smaller splash of vanilla carefully
combine fill the moat
and add whatever fruit you've got now
this is delicious all in its own but if
you're feeling like a creme brulee
moment you're going to add a little bit
of brown sugar on top all right we're
gonna pop this into a 350 degree oven
till the custard is set and we got a
nice golden Browning on top
oh it's packed with protein we got
healthy fats we got high fiber carbs
your 90s diet culture we're gonna
bring Bagels back for good